Evil alien invaders are coming in
November. Yeah, that's what we're being
told by the mainstream media news. We
know that there is a satanic agenda to
make the world believe that there are
alien visitors and that there's good
aliens and there's bad aliens and that
the good aliens are going to come at a
time of great calamity. When there's
earthquakes and disasters and pandemics,
then the cosmic saviors, our cosmic
brothers and sisters are going to come
at just the right time when the world
needs a savior. And they're going to
say, "We've been watching you just
trying to help you, protect you, guide
you, just like they said in the Marvel
Eternals movie, right?
>> We came here 7,000 years ago to protect
humans from the deviants.
>> We have watched unguided. We have helped
them progress throughout the years. We
have never interfered until now.
>> All predictive programming. Once these
demons in disguise, masquerading as
visitors from other worlds, gain our
trust, then they're going to say, "We
are here to help you in a war that's
coming because an evil alien invader is
coming to take over Earth. And if you
don't side with us, demons, you're never
going to survive." Guess who the evil
alien invader is? None other than Christ
with all his angels. When you read the
Bible alone, who is coming to earth to
destroy it? Christ alone. Who is the one
that's trying to save earth? Satan. When
he rounds the militaries of the world to
fight against Christ. If you're not on
Christ's side, you will be destroyed by
the brightness of his coming. But if
you're on his side, you will be changed
in the moment, in a twinkle of an eye,
and be caught up to meet the Lord in the
air. All this propaganda, all these
movies that come out, something's
coming. It's an asteroid. It's Thanos.
It's the evil alien invaders. We must
put aside all our differences and band
together because it's us against them.
Humanity is going to be destroyed. It's
all satanic propaganda. Every single
movie is the same movie. The stage is
being set for Satan to unite the world
in a false peace and safety. We hear it
right from Trump's mouth.
>> Peace and security for the world.
>> It's all lining up with the Bible.
Prophecy is coming true right before our
very eyes. Nobody in the history of the
world has ever faced a deception like we
are about to face. Be ready for his soon
return. He's coming like a thief in the
night. Are you ready?